one couple was able to get a gift of a
new ac unit from a local organization
that's right the couple says they
considered it life-saving victoria saha
has this eight news now exclusive
living in southern nevada you can't
imagine being at home without the air
conditioning on during the summer months
while one couple living in this house
behind me had to endure weeks without it
when their ac unit broke until help
finally came when the hot temperature
outside nearly matches the temps inside
your home you would try anything for
some relief this is
the tower that i put on my head with the
ice pack the house that anna-lysa frame
and her husband mufud corey live in was
built in the 70's they their ac unit was
barely hanging on until it stopped
working completely in june do you
remember the day
when your ac unit broke how was the
temperature outside
it was a hundred and
hundred
or spy
and how did it feel inside
and to replace a new one was going to
cost them more than eleven thousand
dollars money they did not have we were
sleeping in 92 degree or 94 degree
weather for almost five weeks family
referred them to an organization called
rebuilding together southern nevada
helping low-income families get home
essentials and this week they helped the
couple finally feel the cool air inside
their home again right now it feels so
good in here we feel
like it was a god's gift to us executive
director bob cleveland was personally
there to see the installation for
himself you walk into a house and it's
95 degrees you're like how do you live
like this this is part of our county
funding and we're just very blessed to
be able to help them a gift no one
should be without i don't know how we
would have survived this summer if you
or anyone you know needs their ac unit
repair rebuilding together wants you to
apply but applicants need to be
considered as low income we have more
information up on our website at eight
news now dot com victoria zaha live
local now